hey everyone welcome to my next video
today I'm gonna talk about pathfinding
and specifically about the a-star
algorithm which is really popular in
games what I'll do today is go over the
core of the algorithm going through some
explanations and providing pseudocode
and then walking through some examples
step by step so that you can see and
understand how it works really
thoroughly I also have full source code
in JavaScript available online at the
github address in the description so you
can check that out if you're interested
in the future I'll have some more
advanced tutorials that walk through
some of the ways to make the algorithm
more efficient but today we'll keep it
simple and we'll focus on getting a grip
on the basics so to begin what is the
a-star algorithm at its core it's a
graph traversal algorithm in very much
the same way that depth-first search or
breadth-first search shall graph
traversal algorithms in fact you can use
depth-first search or breadth-first
search to tooth path finding it's just
incredibly inefficient but it works the
key difference between a star and
depth-first search or breadth-first
search is in the heuristic which
attempts to steer the algorithm towards
the goal instead of blindly iterating
the entire graph until the goal is found
in games especially games with dynamic
environments where things can be blocked
one minute and open the next you know
you you blow up a door or something like
that a star is commonly used to find
paths for units from point A to point B
so before we look at the pseudocode here
are some quick definitions things that a
star relies heavily on and you should
have a grip on them you'll see in here
references to both in F score and a G
score throughout in both the pseudocode
and in the examples we'll walk through
so it's really important to at least get
these two concepts down G score is
really straightforward at any point on
the map between the start in the end
when you want to calculate the G score
it refers to the distance or kind of the
cost of moving all the way from the
start
to the current point you could imagine
if you are a person in a maze for
example this would be this would be how
many steps you took to get to where you
are it's not that the bird's-eye view
distance it's literally the walking
distance so including going around
corners up stairs things like that
f-score is a little more complex at any
point on the map you you know how long
it took to get there but you're not sure
how far the way it is from the goal so
the F score is the sum of the cost to
get to that point plus a guess at how
far away you are from the end so going
back to our maze example if you're at
some random spot in the maze you know
how many steps it took to get there and
the estimated distance to the goal could
just be the distance from that spot to
the goal ignoring the wall so if you
were to draw the map from above it would
just be a line straight from that point
to the goal here's the pseudocode let's
take a quick look what a star is doing
it keeps what's called an open list
which is sorted by F score and every
step in the algorithm it takes the node
with the lowest F score checks out all
the nodes connected to that one and
calculates the G score for each of them
if that new G score is lower than the
current G score for that node it adds it
to the open list if it wasn't already in
the open list here's a picture that
hopefully will clear things up so you've
got this guy standing in the maze trying
to find his way through he's kind of
walked down and around the first wall so
his cheese coorg could just be how far
he walked to get to that point he's at
now so I kind of drew his footprints and
blue there and you can you can follow
them and if you were looking from above
say from a bird's eye view you could see
roughly how far this little guy is from
the end of the maze again ignoring the
walls in this picture I just called that
the H distance in code is often referred
to as the heuristic function now the F
score which is really so important
making a star work it's just the sum of
these and it's G + H
so it's the G score or how far you've
walked to get to the spot in the maze
plus the H score or the guess as to how
far you are away from the end so this
still sounds a little complicated we'll
walk through some examples step by step
in the first example we'll start at the
top left and you can see that the X is
just a few squares away when we start
we'll calculate the F and G scores since
we started at this point the G score or
how long it took to get here is zero
since it didn't take any time to get
here then we started here you can also
see that we're about four squares away
from the X so it stands that the
heuristic would guess that it's about
four away and so the F score which is G
Plus H is four
since this is zero plus four now if you
remember the pseudocode we choose the
open node with the lowest app score
which in this case is the top left since
it's the only one and then we expand out
every node that connects to that one in
this case since we're only allowing left
right and up down walking we expand out
the nodes below and to the right you can
see that the G score for each of these
nodes it's one since it took one step to
get there the F score for the one below
is a little higher because it's actually
a little bit further away from the goal
so once you count the distance from that
to the goal and you add one you end up
with a higher you end up with a higher F
score the F score for the one on the
right is still four because G is one but
now you're only three squares away so H
would be three and one plus three is
four so let's do another round of
updates and now we'll check out some
more neighbors and you can see if the G
scored for all the new neighbors is two
since it takes two steps to get to each
of these new ones and the F score for
the one on the right is still four so
it's now your only two away from the
goal and the G score to get there was
two
updating again we expand only one
neighbor this time because it's blocked
underneath and you can see that the F
and G scores updated similarly to how
they did before and finally in this last
step we hit the goal and in this case
the G score is four because it took four
squares of movement to get there but
since we're at the goal the distance to
the goal is zero and so the F score is
four because that's G Plus whose H which
is four plus zero
slightly more complicated example this
one will lead us a bit away from the
goal at first before eventually moving
back towards it we can see in the first
step two neighbors are expanded and the
green one was the one with the lowest F
score so it's chosen now we know that we
need to go down and around the wall
before hitting the goal since you can
see the whole map but a star can't see
the entire map like this in the next
step you can see that the next node
chosen was the one directly under the
start since among the open nodes it had
the lowest F score after that bottom one
has expanded it chooses to go to the one
on the right and two more nodes are
expanded below and to the right this
time a star decides to try for that
little crevice in the wall since there's
potentially the best chance of getting
to the goal now we can see that it's not
we can see that this is a dead-end
but like I said a star doesn't see the
entire map it only sees one note at a
time and whatever it's seen in the past
so it's back to expanding and we can see
as this moves along all that's doing
over and over is checking out some new
nodes assigning G and F scores to each
one and then choosing to explore the one
with the lowest F score eventually it
checks out all the nodes on the left
side of the map and now we can see it's
starting to creep around the bottom of
the wall as it does that the F score is
starting to stabilize and you can see
that it's starting to make a beeline for
the goal notice how it's considering but
not exploring the nodes on the right
side you can see that the F score
leading to the goal is now 10 and those
F scores on the right are 11 point one
six and eleven point two four at this
point so they're now going to be
explored by the a-star algorithm unless
it can't get to the gold with the nodes
that's exploring right now this is all
working on these small toy examples
let's throw some harder maps at this
thing I coated up a really quick maze
generator let's see how the a-star
implementation handles some much bigger
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so it looks like our a star
implementation was doing fine but we
broke the bass generator it looks like I
have to rewrite this thing as an
iterative algorithm anyway hopefully
this is all clear
like I said source code is available on
github
next time we'll do a deep dives through
the actual code and implementation and
we'll talk about some optimization
opportunities and trade-offs as well